poom and we're live and well I yeah a
little closer a little closer all right
don't worry fellow okay how you doing
very nice to meet you nice to meet you
too
you're remarkably normal oh thanks I
know people are we struck at how normal
I am am i it's like wow really I think
my roommate a shoe the maze I guess
seeing a famous child and yeah yeah
that's a very unusual maze yeah my life
is unique to me that's what I like to
say you know yeah and I'm almost like a
peerless person like to a certain extent
there's not too many people I can look
left and right and we you know I I'm
like we have similar experiences yes
there anybody that you ever contacted
like Jodie Foster or someone who's made
it through and seems pretty put together
not really no not really I mean it's
kind of a weird cold call you know hey
Jodie Foster such a small clan of people
like if a comic called me that I knew
you know who wanted to talk to me I
would talk to them because it's such a
small people I mean we do have our
weekly therapy sessions yeah
Jodie Foster you know yeah like we all
get together and yeah we we weep you
know actually we do primal screaming
that's what we do I was describing when
it was like I have a friend who Ricky
Schroder who is you know obviously he
was very famous for news young as well
and one of my favorite theme songs TV
theme songs and I was saying like the
way you developed is not like the way
the recipe calls mmm-hmm like the recipe
calls for you to have a childhood and
try to figure out life and then become a
man and try to find yourself and then
try to find your path and by the time
you became a man he was already famous
and the same thing with you you were
already famous as you were developing
and learning yeah you know yeah III
don't know exactly how to like kind of
even describe it because it's always the
way my life has been kind of thing
getting the same way that like a lot of
kids like you know they go out
and they you know catch bugs and play
saying lot baseball or whatever like
yeah just like yeah like that's the way
it is like you don't really realize how
unique the whole situation is until you
have perspective because you have
nothing to compare it to really other
than I guess TV shows and movies things
like that so I knew that my upbringing
was unique you know I knew it was
different but at the same time it kind
of just it's not until you get some
perspective some life experience but
until you really realize that oh wait
this was this was particularly weird you
know I think one of the aspects is
particularly worried about it is a lot
of kids that grow up famous they grow up
on the set yeah and they grow up
constantly around people who treat them
very differently than everyone else it's
not just that you're famous is that
you're famous and you're also the
complete center of attention mm-hmm like
you're the reason why we're here we're
here to do this television show we're
here to do this movie we're here to do
this thing you're the star mm-hmm and
that I think for a kid that's a very
strange place to be yeah and especially
like I mean I like when I was a kid like
me even before I started working I
always liked being like the center of
attention kind of thing I was too you
know I was just I was very boisterous
you know but uh but in general like I
never really liked being fussed over
when I didn't like you know like at the
hair makeup costume people like poking
at you all the time and things like they
actually wasn't a huge fan after a while
of kind of like being that at center of
attention you know it it does become a
job after a while yeah yeah like early
on you kind of just do what you do like
that's like I was good at it and boom
liked it in the same way like that you
do look anything that you're like you
like it's where the child labor laws
don't apply to actor you do do that
yeah I'm pretty well-versed in child
labor laws well how's that work then it
goes from state to state they can work
you like let's say like in New York they
can work you ten hours yeah but it
stopped right there they can work you
well if you can't get a job if they're
eight that's what you're that's what
you're kind of like that's what their
limit is at the same time you have to
get three hours of schooling in plus an
hour of lunch so really you're only
you're available window is only six
hours or something like that
all right day and then like that also in
like in that six hours they're always
like setting up the lights for the next
shot and you know the hurry-up-and-wait
kind of part of you know
things that's why I like the second home
alone it took like nearly five months to
film because they can only mean
virtually every scene and they can only
use me X amount of hours a day kind of
thing but that isn't that the only job
that you can work when you're eight
years old I don't know why you can't be
a carpenter I mean I guess you can do
modeling you know I mean but like some
kind of performing arts kind of thing
like there are dancers and so forth
mm-hmm
because I would say I was a ballet
dancer before I was an actor really yeah
I did ballet for a number of years I'm a
classically trained ballerina right here
ballerina if you're a man I call it I
say I'm a ballet dancer hmm
but there is a weird ballarino like that
some of the Meuse and I'm like I'm not I
don't think I can call myself a
ballerina look I just can't it's two
bros so I did that for a number of years
and there's a bunch of kids like any
that do that and you get paid and you do
the work Wow
so you know there are other I guess
trades yeah it seems like it's no
business though yeah yeah that's what I
mean I think it's more in the performing
arts kind of thing like you know you
don't see a lot of kids working the coal
mines anymore like that kind of thing
yeah for good reason alright but some
people think that my six-year-old dyeing
a black lung you know there's some
horrible pictures from like the early
1900s of people actually working in the
coal mines when they're little tiny kids
yep yep yeah I mean there are no Newsies
anymore you know look yeah did you have
any say in whether or not you worked
when you were young not really no yeah
look it was after a while it became like
I said a job and it was I like I never
chose the projects they were like my
parents can you essentially like chose
them for me so you'll news McCallie yeah
exactly yeah yeah they called you in a
class and like I never read any two
scripts look I would I would just read
like the lines for like the next day or
whatever like I would like get the gist
of what the movie was about but then I
just kind of show up and
hit my marks find my light you know you
know and recite my lines so real it's
kind of just like again it's what you do
right like it's like in the same way
that like like kids go to like school or
something like that like you know you
you you follow to a routine to a certain
extent yeah well that's the thing about
the human mind right so flexible mhm you
could adopt any sort of weird scenario
especially when you're a kid I mean okay
you just bounce look all the time it's
adapt so easy
exactly exactly and I always had like a
good memory and things like that like
you know I liked you know I was I was
big and charismatic and I like had a
good memory like so I could remember my
lines like that's pretty much what like
if you you know like not gonna give any
advice to any people about like yeah you
should put your kid into this line of
work but at the same time like what
producers really care about is whether
or not you remember your lines but they
like people you know never work with
kids or animals kind of thing yeah it's
like yeah and they want they they really
all they really care about is you
remember your lines really like because
apparently that's a problem like for me
it never was look if I ever lost my
place I would just see the script in my
head and just read it look I think I
kind of had a photographic memory back
then
oh it's faded now I'm 37 I'm about to be
38 in like two weeks
feels weird doesn't it yeah you know
yeah look uh my my bowels are different
what's different about your bow oh yeah
I know just like I like I just got a uh
doing some like random checkup kind of
thing and they're like oh we should
scope you you know so they also you know
they I did the scoping like you know in
my stomach kind of thing but they also
you know I got a colonoscopy so I was
actually hoping like usually were put me
under so I was like it didn't really
matter to me but I was gonna put you
under for a colonoscopy yeah yeah you
know at least I had that anus coping so
I think I don't know again it's down the
throat I was hoping I was actually
hoping they were going to use the but
one first and then put it in my mouth
just ass to mouth boom look at me up but
no no they apparently they use different
cameras
yeah the probably designed different
yeah all goes deep right but uh because
they were like all worried I might have
an ulcer oh into the veins or something
yeah again kind of it's been a little
iffy and so the good news is I didn't
have an ulcer bad news is I have two
ulcers yeah so I'm dealing with that
I've had to like curtail my lifestyle in
general like I'm eating less red meat
you know less carbonated beverages like
ibuprofen no more ibuprofen like there's
no fans terrible for you good yeah
exactly so look I've had to like you
know I used to like eat like burgers
every single day and now it's like I can
have two servings of red meat a week
kind of thing and what it wasn't too
hard for me to curtail my lifestyle like
as smoking less trying to drink less
like things like that what's the logic
behind red meat less I think I I'm not
the doctor yeah it's like if you read
the list of like yeah things that are
good or bad for your alter some things
that aggravate it yeah exactly so red
meat like falls into that category like
it was a funny microwave but chicken
doesn't fish doesn't apparently not or
at least you know less so weird and yeah
might because my special lady friend she
was like you know worried about me and
stuff so she was reading up on like you
know ulcers and things like that and it
was like the first like it was like
seven things that like that flared up
and all of them were like checkmarks
really exactly what I was doing in my
life kind of thing like you know I had
like I said red meats smoking drinking
like I had just had like a neck issue so
I was taking a lot of ibuprofen like you
know and it was just like every single
checkmark you know so yeah I've read
something about ibuprofen doing it
because ibuprofen disrupts gut bacteria
and they believe that gut bacteria but
was there was something really recent
about that a real recent study they
think that they found a new cause for
ulcers like they've changed what they
think these two thing was caused by
stress which can do it like also look I
just again I have also had like I've
just started a new company and things
like that so like I have that kind of
stress like kind of thing like you know
like look I said I hit a lot of the
checkmarks looking when you say can do
it I think what they were saying was
they used to think it can do it but now
they think it's all a matter of bacteria
in your stomach yeah I mean I think
that's a big part of
also if you like cuz I did a movie in
Thailand like last year and came back
you know came back with a worm so you
know what are those like single-cell
kind of like you know when I was getting
the medication for it I was like so what
do i what should I expect from this he's
like what do you expect you to get
better
I go yeah but like you know what's like
sit am I gonna [ __ ] a worm am I gonna
[ __ ] out and they're like no no no one
of those single-cell ones but it made me
more susceptible to like getting ulcers
you know so is this because the
antibiotics that you had to take for the
worm or I mean I think it just it messes
with your stomach chemistry kind of
thing so after that is when you got the
old yeah exactly exactly so you know
dealing with it like it's actually it's
actually not so bad
look you know like so how's it do do how
does it what does it alter do you know
sometimes you kind of get a little pain
things like then um yeah like I mean at
one point I was like [ __ ] like 10
times a day kind of thing you know what
I mean like it was kind of just like
kind of loosened your stool a little bit
yeah yeah couldn't get some mucus II
like I mean I can go in go into it
that's what I mean you're asking me yeah
I find this stuff fascinating
like what just came out of me right when
you can't see what's going on it's like
behind a door yeah that's happening to
it yeah I was like what was that was
that chicken I don't know like which
meal was that one like you know a guy
I'm experimenting with my stomach seeing
what it comes out the other end kind of
thinking again
did you experiment at all with
probiotics did you do anything to try to
yeah this is a fairly recent thing this
has only been like the last like not
even two months looking last like him
yeah like eight weeks or so so like I am
just kind of easing into this thing I
have a list I made a little list or like
things that are good for me looking or
like to eat it things like that like you
know make sure I get some yogurt like
lots of leafy greens you know ribbon on
you jacket you have pinned to the safety
pin it's a participation badge
participate in life look at me yeah I
mean I I mean I went to a UH it was a
camp like a summer camp themed wedding
back in like almost a year ago some like
that and so like they were giving out
participation badges like kind of thing
because if you participated in things
but ya know everyone always asked me
about
the ribbon like yeah I kind of just a
safety pin yeah yeah kind of just you
know I mean I wear like all kinds of
things but for some reason everyone's
like what is that what's that look no
I'm participating in life here I am
aren't I
look here I'm on your podcast you are
participating I am participating you
seem really healthy like you seem like a
like a together person oh yeah I know
that it's really stuck in a shocker for
people I guess so look you know I'm
actually usually for the most part I'm
pretty put together look at yeah look I
I got a good life now I got have a
special lady friend we have a dog and a
cat
oh yeah yeah it's for a family yeah
exactly like there's one thing to like
exchange keys it's another to get a cat
you know so we we had as you can get a
cat together cuz cat can kind of go
anywhere
yeah get a dog together that's it that's
a big one it's a certain yeah she
already had the dog but it's like it's a
it's a it's a girl and she's a what is
she but you knew oh yeah door but looks
like a stuffed animal kind of thing and
then we have a cheese black and then we
got a big fluffy white cat it's like boy
girl dog cat like you know yeah like you
know yeah like it's they're really
really and they're adorable look I've
seen dogs and cats play with each other
before and it's kind of cute and these
guys play all the time it's actually
like it's a very special little
relationship that they have so oh yeah
no we never turn on the television
licking our house just watch just watch
like the dog and the cat and stuff you
know yeah do you do you plan on making
people oh yeah yeah no I want I want I'm
gonna make some babies you know all that
kind of stuff so get this one so this
one's a good one so you know I'm
probably gonna put some babies in her
looking a little bit you know I mean we
definitely been practicing but yeah but
but yeah no yeah no this wasn't again
gonna have a gonna have some pretty
babies she's a she's Asian so I'm gonna
have like yeah I'm gonna have little
tiny little Asian babies yeah it's nice
yeah it's it's gonna be adorable look at
that door a bunch a bunch of Shawn
linens running around the house that's
what I'm looking for because it's funny
like you know like I I'm like it's
almost like I feel entitled to make like
Asian jokes because I have an Asian
girlfriend kind of thing okay you're
loud I don't think I'm well I do it with
her like all the time but like I don't
do anybody know yeah
it's like it's like oh it's like a baby
you're my Yoko like you know just like
you know like it's like you you're gonna
be my downfall you're the most hated
person in all of music yeah exactly
exactly used to be able to if you were
married to an Asian woman 10-15 years
ago I think if I I think if I have Asian
babies I'd be allowed to think so man I
don't even think so because you know I
I'd had to deal with it every kind of
like day kind of thing it's like oh well
like I can you know I understand the
struggle kind of things you know I'm
trying to shield my kids
white male wealthy white male who's
famous you don't have a chance I guess I
know right privileged blond-haired Aryan
male who grew up famous yeah exactly
they're just warming their fingers up
right there probably write a blog about
you thinking that you can make Asian
trip I know I know I know well that was
one of the things that like you know one
of the things I really loved about her
like was I remember when I made my first
like Asian crack look and I just wanted
this and she could have like stopped and
then she was like laughs she was like I
can't believe you said that
like what was it I said I said you know
how I know you're Asian she goes why I
said this is shape your eyes it's dead
giveaway she could stop that's funny
you're allowed to say that yeah I can't
say because the way you drive [ __ ] yeah
I know exactly yeah you have to have a
really like good sense of humor to
accept that yeah exactly yeah but you
know have a special relationship where
you guys talk to each other it's like
baby you are such a good driver like
just you know like just like you know
she's like shut up would you stop with
the Asian stuff like oh yeah cuz you
actually eat she is an excellent driver
so well you could tell her you're a
really good driver for you know
no why that's weird forget I even
brought it up I'm like so not racist I
don't even understand what exactly like
believe me I'm pretty relentless but her
family like they also like their they're
down with like yeah it's it's I wouldn't
even call it a teasing it's just like
you're just telling jokes kind of thing
looking yeah because I'm the only time
cuz I'm the only white boy like you know
whenever we visit the family I got yeah
it's the foot brand evasion its Ty Lee
Ocean oh wow yeah yeah I know I know the
ocean yeah yeah I just got back from
Thailand oh yeah yeah first time ever
that's where I caught my worm yeah yeah
so what is this worm like did you fight
it was it under your skin was I didn't
know I mean look I single-celled kind of
when it's in your stomach
Oh was in your stomach yeah yeah how did
you know you had it I had a lot of
fatigue and again like just like my
movements weren't all that great like
things like that
and I remember waking up after about
like a good like week or so of it we had
just wrapped up like we were like there
for like five six weeks or something so
I was back in the States and it was just
I was sleeping like 20 hours a day and
like only like waking up to like yeah
like you know just like just [ __ ] pretty
much and then and then ya know I
actually I remember waking up one of
those days and I said I'm pretty sure I
have a worm looking actually just popped
in my head I go like this is probably
what a worm feels like it was almost
kind of a mono s kind of like you know
fatigue like that kind of thing so ya
know
went there and some like heavy-duty
antibiotics for like 10 days how do they
think you caught it I'm not sure look oh
you were on heavy-duty antibiotics ten
days that's probably what caused your
ulcer yeah exactly you know I mean like
the worm doesn't help and then the heavy
duty antibiotics and like all that stuff
it's just kind of look at him you know
and also again like lifestyle like kind
of things you know like you're just like
yeah like you know like I can't pound
bourbon like I used to kind of thing
look even like that's kind of the idea
right so um but ya know it was so I
think I caught it from a cat because
there was actually like a we were in a
it was Co PP
we that that island and that's like Cat
Island stuff and yeah we had these
little bungalows and I remember I was
like we were just kind of checking in
and I pulled my bag up and this
a little like kind of kitten just like
walked up and just like hey can I come
in
look yeah sure come on in look I've had
a lot of cats in my life and stuff so
yeah that little that little sucker like
like spent a lot of time and things like
that and that's probably exactly like
we'd sleep in the bed together and so
like that I like sherbert you know like
you know tested for Toxoplasma
toxoplasmosis I've actually had that
before we don't have it then yeah you
have for life yeah exactly
no I went through the symptoms I caught
it from an undercooked piece of lamb
actually yeah yeah it's one of the four
ways you can get it kind of thing no
kidding yeah you can get it from yet
from cats you can get it from
undercooked lamb you can get it through
a blood transfusion and I think the
other one is a mother can transfer it to
its bitty to the to their baby
well yeah believe me I I went to the
whole CDC website and everything like I
mean and that was like mono kind of
thing like a lot of people catch it but
they like they just have the antibodies
for it and I was a little rundown I was
doing a play in London for like ten
months and also like kind of going out
at night and things like that so I think
my body was kind of just like not its
strongest and boom and hit me like a ton
of bricks like it was that was like mono
kind of thing and I was totally run down
its I got better after about like three
months or so but I didn't get a hundred
percent better for about a year there
was a crazy article just written about
talk so that it had some sort of impact
on people who are who start up
businesses that they're launched from
more entrepreneurs have toxoplasmosis
it's a it radically affects behavior
apparently oh yeah I mean I don't know
hey I got it when I was like 20 so I'm
gonna yeah so makes you more risk-taking
more more makes you more there yeah
parasite found in cat poo has been
linked to higher likelihood of
entrepreneurial behavior in people who
get infected yeah well I just launched
my own website recently kind of stuff
you know yeah so there you go yeah III
blame the toxoplasmosis have you read up
on it a lot I mean many of Robert
Sapolsky stuff no no no not in a while
like you know I mean like I said I
caught this like in like 2000 2001
Roberts and Paul skis he's a professor
at Stanford and
he's a biologist and he's he specializes
in toxoplasmosis and primate behavior
and a lot of other different he's
biologists right so this is a discipline
yeah but anyway he he's got some amazing
talks on it you really should listen to
it since you have it yeah yeah it's
fascinating stuff they found a
disproportionate number of motorcycle
victims people motorcycle crashes taking
okay that's what you're saying yeah
that's actually that's fascinating yeah
it you know how it works at the it only
can only reproduce inside the cat's gut
mm-hmm and it rewires the sexual reward
system of a rat so it makes a rat horny
it smells cat piss oh so it completely
changes the cat's sexual reward system
yeah no that makes sense the the
evolutionary advantage you know not to
have it
absolution air advantage it's it's it
actually tricks the the cat into killing
the rap and tricks the rat into being
horny you'll examine a to come around
exactly that's what I mean there's an
evolutionary advantage to the man
because like yet look if you if you're a
cat and you have toxoplasmosis like it's
going to you know it's going to attract
your prey to you well it actually
doesn't no it doesn't work that way
um the rat has to be infected when the
rats infected then it smells cat urine
and gets horny when the cats infected it
doesn't do anything to the cat yeah it
seems to have no change in the behavior
of the cat but then it gets to people
yeah so it only affects really the
behavior people and rats yeah it's weird
yeah but ya know I I caught it I got
they got the antibodies for it or
whatever yeah it's one of those like
forever kind of things but it doesn't
affect me like at all
like you mean like there's no how would
you oh yes I mean look at no it's look
at it's just it's a it was one of those
things were like yeah I got sick for for
a couple of months and then like I said
it was like mono
I think the disproportionate number of
successful soccer teams that come from
countries that are of high rates of
Toxoplasma infection I should get into
soccer well it's just one of those
things it's just it changes the way
people behave
make some make it a little Wilder so
you're saying you're you're interested
in some toxoplasmosis and
you have it yeah top so you're tuk-tuk
so Gandhi or whatever is looking in
mmm-hmm walks with Madison was this
movie in Thailand is my buddy a Seth
Green was he wrote and directed a movie
and so he asked me to do something in it
and you know like I don't really pursue
acting I got all kind of thing you know
and I'm not saying it was a favor
anything at the same time it was like
yeah it sounds like fun
so at school cast it's like him he's in
it brick admires and it brings a song me
so do you just like do whatever you want
these days and just occasionally act
when it comes up yeah if it comes up
like you know if it's a cool like neat
little gig or something that like yeah
sure but like I said I don't pursue it
in any kind of like any way like I don't
have agents anymore and things like that
is that because you're just not
interested yeah I don't really like the
the pursuit of it you know like yeah
like what yeah exactly I just like I
don't like being on the circuit kind of
thing looking yeah so but yeah I know I
am
you know I write a lot I paint a lot
like I just kind of always have like
some kind of projects and then also like
I said we got the website bunny ears um
kind of thing and what is that that is
it's a comedy website it's pretty much
like like you know how all these
celebrity especially like ladies they
have those lifestyle websites all of
them well a lot of them do you know look
at like goop you know is there other
ones oh yeah yeah no it's okay it's a
goop ones the most egregious though yeah
that's that well that's the thing is
that so this is this is like goop meets
the onion soup is like goop meets the
onion yeah I know well yeah but
accidentally you put Jade balls up your
vagina I know believe me we had a lot of
years
yeah we have a beach in a hole does it
just do that thing Oh annoying yeah yeah
I'd have sex on a beach in a hot tub and
other things that seemed fun as a virgin
mm-hmm and it's Hannah Hannah you know
Michael he's a Hana she's a fantastic
writer you have a little scroll and
things like so you have a podcast as
well yeah we do a podcast also um and
we're we have so we're revving up some
more like video content and things but
uh yeah so this is just a fun project
yeah it's it's
got a lot of really great writers like
comedy writers and stuff and you know
it's kind of just like oh look there's a
good article about a JTAG like oh i put
a jade egg up my vagina and I catch a
jade bird you know like that kind of
thing like you know and then like you
know what to do about your bird living
in your vagina now it's like I mean
we're kind of like taking the piss out
of like you know some of these kind of
like lifestyle websites you know it's
like um it's like you know they'll have
articles a gun coupe about like oh the
best Cabernet is like for like $200 or
something that and it's like ours is
like the best Bourbons under you know
$20 but then like a turn the spelling
gets worse and worse and then it turns
into a rant about your ex-girlfriend so
like like that it's it's it's some
really good stuff like I said we have a
really really great team of people and
yeah it's it's kind of like I said
taking the piss out of things so you
just decided to do this just for fun
yeah I kind of had this idea with kind
like kicking it around and so forth and
then I felt like I kind of accumulated
enough ideas and then uh yeah then I
start kind of Voltron ting it like just
grab it and assembling you know like
this this this you know this this
project this giant giant robot you know
yeah so there you go it's it's a lot of
fun it's and it's it is funny like we
have to like I said there's actually
look those articles are really
well-written like we have one about do
you see infinity war yeah the Avengers
no okay yeah oh it's fantastic it's
fantastic but maybe like we made our own
Infinity Gauntlet and what happens is
like I know
spoiler alert is I got a lot of the
people to kind of just vanish like they
kind of just died like you know they
turn into dust in the movie in the movie
at the end so like when you start
reading the article eight all of a
sudden just all the words just start
vanishing it's like you know and then
you have to go back and again it's like
yeah even like the letters like we
actually had a um we did one where it
was a ransom letter one of our writers
she her father is actually the therapist
for a group like the extra like
psychiatrist the official one so we do
pass their own therapist yeah you know
yes but is it like a weekly advice
therapist or is it just like therapy
just for being on goop I know you're
here because you're a master here just
read this read this it's going
so we're here for you hug so we got
pictures of him bound and gagged and
it's like deer goop like we we kidnapped
your therapist we can only get him back
if you give us your seven hot tips for
you know yeah like a for facial washers
for this summer look like and you know
what they actually good on them they
responded and they actually like sent us
over like a list of like here the hot
like kind of like you know good for them
like data sense of humor about the whole
thing
like anything half do they're called
goop right yeah we almost we thought
about naming ours pug yeah I know yeah
like you know no no so so you're
basically financially set from all those
movies so I do okay for myself but do
you just put that money away and just
live off the interest pretty much you
know yeah and yeah I'm able to kind of
live the life that you know like then I
that my circumstances afforded me I'm
I'm like I said I'm very very very lucky
um you know lots of weird things happen
to kids all the time all around the
world every day you know I I have
something to show for it you know like
yeah like you know so it's nice okay I
can live it's a my buddy jacking cause
it's a weird way to describe a movie
career yeah pretty much
weird things happen to kids yeah I've
got some money out of it look I'm not
working like the diamond mines I'm not a
child soldier you know what I mean you
know I came out the other end uh and I
have something to show for it and I'm
very like I I do feel blessed every
morning kind of thing you're happy that
it all worked out that way yeah yeah you
could go back and do it again when you
do the same way uh knowing what I know
now I mean probably you know I thought
yeah I probably be even more charming I
do it just better
of course you would right yeah exactly
yeah imagine if you just have your brain
a little kids body yeah I know I would
kill it grade school I would so kill it
like in school oh the warfare they know
what's coming yeah a little [ __ ] yeah
I was Alastair little brains up and not
exactly I don't it would that would be
great I'm pretty sure that's what a
thirty good going on thirteen was right
Jennifer Gardner movie yeah yeah I have
no idea what any Jennifer garden was
well you know
now you do like a brain swap one kind of
yes but she like yeah her adult brain so
it's kind of a freaky friday with some
time travel I guess uh-huh
so yeah so you're gonna gonna Netflix it
tonight aren't you nope I can see it I I
you've been thoroughly charmed by a
Jennifer Gardner
that's no interesting life you have then
you so you just kind of do whatever you
want yeah my friend Jenks is I'm a man
of leisure that's the way he describes
like my life and lifestyle that's a good
way to describe it it's true and look I
kind of like him kind of you know spend
some time just like jumping around like
Europe or something like that and like
you know and just look at and look at
well you lived in Paris you were saying
yeah I was well yeah lived there for a
number of years I mean I still have I
stole my place there but uh since like
like 2013 so I mean that it's only the
last year I've been kind of spending
more time in the States was it that
brought you to Paris well the food sucks
the wines terrible and the women are
ugly but uh but otherwise it's it's
fantastic yeah no it's okay it was an
agreeable lifestyle I Ament your friends
out there there was always asking me
we're gonna move to Paris and when you
learn French what your friends in Paris
yes yeah and I was there just kind of
like I was just kind of jumping around a
little bit and so I thought about it for
a second I went you know what how's next
week so I said I gotta leave my bags
here I'm gonna fly back to New York I'm
gonna going you know I'll put my affairs
in order and I said I'll be back next
week I said I'm ready to live here I
mean I realized that if I could pick up
and just move to France on a whim and it
wouldn't affect like you know like
anyone's life or wouldn't hurt anybody
or iView remissed if I didn't look you
don't I mean like yeah like how many
times am I like I couldn't do that now
but I could do it back then kind of
thing right so I was like yeah like no I
should just [ __ ] it look I'm I'm good
I'm gonna live in Paris now you know
yeah and it was it was great
it was a lot of people have done that
Johnny Depp lived there for a little
while I know really there for a while
no it's a special place and what's
special about it I mean again food mines
fantastic like the girls are pretty look
it's the leisurely kind of like
lifestyle a little bit like I like I
like their eating habits you know like
it's like a light breakfast and kind of
gets heavier as you kind of go along in
the day you kind of eat later which is
kind of like you know like like oh
you're American you must want to eat
dinner at like 8:00
I like 10:00 you know again p.m. yeah
about 10:00 p.m. is like a you know kind
of a you know an ideal like dinner kind
of time they don't like to work hard
either right I mean no I mean they I
mean they work I mean I think you know
but I like to take their time and yeah
everything is like yeah it's a you know
I'll set up a card game for like 3:30
like in 3:30 means like 5:00 you know
again that's just the way like
everyone's kind of always late but it's
no big deal that's the thing I remember
one time kind of like oh gosh like you
know just like where are they and then I
realize I'm like wait what is the hurry
look for real like what is the hurry
like it's like I have other plans my
plan is to hang out like you know with
you guys and so and all of a sudden like
stress would just kind of just melt away
I'm like yeah like look you can just be
more leisurely and stuff about things
out there and everyone's again like I
said it's really cool they like
Americans out there that's a
misconception if they don't like they
don't like the loud obnoxious Americans
with the you know Mickey Mouse t-shirt
we don't need if ya know you do we say
fanny packs how dare you and I did yeah
nice like leather one you I use inside
pockets I got I got inside oh that's my
purse hmm well that works too
I also have a satchel that I travel
around so look at look at this purse
yeah yeah exactly
yeah you know what it's actually I do
call it my purse like you know and day
to day kind of thing because it's like
someone's like oh it's a satchel or it's
a murse I'm like no no it's a purse look
you know no illusions here isn't it
funny that what you would be insulted or
more positive about it if had a
different sound coming out of your mouth
yeah right it's like no no no it's it's
exact same thing it's a purse yeah so um
what happened there why did men how come
we can't a purses
right no one's gonna do that like me
it's a few bold souls that will put on a
fanny pack and walk out into public yeah
but it's not a lot of people that will
just actually just call yourself bold an
actual person purse yeah you know I mean
I'm secure enough in myself and like
everything like yeah I can pull off the
purse look I mean I wear fingernail
polish and you know I have a
participation badge look I've got like
I'm like you have like fingernail
stripes yeah yeah polish but like a
little bit yeah actually I almost I
actually do do it on purpose
look it's like they do make my fingers a
little too feminine if it's done
perfectly and so but I'm actually really
good when I did that movie party monster
I learned a lot of like just fun makeup
II kind of things and ways to make your
fingers look like they're like you're
like like they're two weeks old when
really like you know yeah like you know
technically I mean I could have like
painted easily yesterday and they would
look like this kind of thing mm-hmm
but uh you know he's always just liked
nail polish what can I say yeah but you
know I'm secure enough to like like wear
a purse or something like that like you
know I want to shoe with that yeah a
backpack though that's where it's weird
what's this Mickey Rourke yeah he's got
what's called a clutch clutch yeah but
he's so eccentric I met him this past
weekend he had a crazy cowboy that's
we're looking at a picture of Mickey
Rourke he had a crazy cowboy hat on and
he's just yeah he seems like a kook I
mean you can see that again here like
that belt buckle like really like that
was you know that's something looking at
like good on him yeah and he's just an
odd duck around yeah yeah
I assume so it reminds me it was an old
onion article and there's one of my
favorite headlines and it was Johnny
Depp bound to be 90 percent scarfs
yeah he got like waist garfi after the
whole pirate movie yeah yeah it went
straight scarf like we're the rest of
his life kind of things like yeah he
really he really committed to that scarf
thing listen when you're a beautiful man
like that it's an odd transition meeting
like a 55 year old I think he's like
what's up with Johnny Depp lately not
good things I know it's it's really
strange actually they just this morning
they delayed or like actually like or
cancelled he is a notorious b.i.g movie
what kind of that he's in with Forest
Whitaker and he was posed to come out
next month and they just pulled it from
the schedule and they haven't like even
said that it's ever gonna come out or
something and it's like and even just
like looking at pictures of him like it
kind of just like there's something off
about him
he used to be really great he's an up
what you do to him you [ __ ] Doug
Stanhope one of the best stand-up
comedians ever there you go he's more of
a stephen wright fan myself me too yeah
I know right
but I think I think Johnny's just he hit
that weird spot where you're just too
[ __ ] famous you can't go anywhere
where you were when you were little
I'm sure again but you can coast now
right you just go places yeah look how
rich is rich enough like dude like Brian
look yeah like that's what it means not
just that we heap spends he owns 14
houses he owns an island millions and
millions of dollars didn't spend like
five billion dollars shooting a hunter
as Thompson's yeah ashes the cannon yeah
did you spend a million dollars no of
course not I spent three million dollars
I think that's they asked him about his
wine habit they said your attorney said
that your wine habit is $30,000 a month
and he goes that's an insult it's far
more far far more than that no I mean
look how I look at all right cool like I
guess he has to maintain you know that
lifestyle well that's what he wants for
himself that's what he's doing that's
his life his life is spending all that
money yeah like his whole life is doing
movie that this is the people though
also when they're involved in laborious
projects that they're not really
interested in mm-hmm
you know when you're when you're doing
something all day and I say this is a
guy who hosted Fear Factor
really enjoy doing while you're doing it
you're like okay time to go to work I
mean it was very thankful to have the
job don't get me wrong but the reality
is it was not enjoy it wasn't a fruitful
endeavor
it wasn't like working for the UFC or
doing stand-up comedy or even doing
apart yeah it wasn't a passion project
exactly so when you do something like
that like people on bad sitcoms in
particular yeah they spend all their
[ __ ] money they go crazy yeah because
the only thing that they look forward to
is what am I gonna do with this money
what's the reward in a buy a Ferrari
yeah buy a mansion and that's I think
that's what Johnny got into yeah I I
couldn't see myself like doing like a
sitcom or a television show kind of
thing like that was not a good super
good one I do like News Radio is a
fantastic show look at that must have
been that that must have been like a
fruitful what's endeavor reason why I
never did another one yeah yeah exactly
don't want to ruin that experience every
other one that came along was like this
is [ __ ] oh they pursued me forever me
for a Big Bang Theory oh and I said like
no I said like nah cuz it was kind of
like the way that pitch was was kind of
just like alright these two like
astrophysicist nerds and then a pretty
girl lives with them yikes like you know
and that was the pitch like yeah it was
like yeah and they're like oh we're
gonna get some real like physicist to
like you don't do the Matt and I should
look at no I said I'm cool like thanks
and then they came back at me again and
I said no no like I'm like again
flattered but like no and then like then
they came back at me again and like even
my manager was like twisting my arm come
on I want a piece but listen I'd have
hundreds of millions of dollars right
now if I did that gig at the same time I
be bashing my head against the wall
that's the thing yeah I think that's
what Johnny Depp's doing and we can't
really be into those pirate movies ya
know he's just he's interested and
that's the thing is that like he wasn't
always like that look now it's like all
about the money well this is the thing I
read an article with an interview with
him that was about two decades ago and
he was talking about you know he was in
his 30s and he was doing a lot of weird
obscure movies like he was that movie
dead man that boy yes yeah
did a lot of weird [ __ ] and he said this
is kind of what I really like and I
don't I'm not blockbuster boy what yeah
I said no it's so ironic it's just so
ironic they doesn't vote [ __ ]
blockbuster boy ya know he goes yeah if
I ever like if you're if I'm ever part
of the guy franchise like just shoot me
or something I'm just like yeah they're
put up he's weird like old quotes it was
a it's a good George Lucas like when he
he testified before Congress about the
colorization of movies mm-hmm I'm
talking about how movies are part of our
heritage and you know they shouldn't be
tampered with or any anything he goes
better he looks like 25 years later he's
going back and redoing his movies like
yeah it's like ya know like once you put
art out there letting it alone leave it
alone no it's not yours anymore
yeah like that's the thing like once you
show like your paintings like that's not
yours anymore that's the world's that's
an interesting way of looking at it I
mean I don't think it's theirs anymore
imagine imagine or DaVinci like like
just all of a sudden came back into
existence right now and he wants to
change the Mona be so she's fat yeah I
didn't get the smile right it's all
pulled back and [ __ ] I want to say so
should he be able to change it I want to
give her some [ __ ] jewelry I never
finished the eyebrows push them together
come on
come on it's my [ __ ] painting yeah
exactly
I met Wiener DaVinci as a moderate a
yeah big tits would [ __ ] glitter it's
like he's like it living on like
Mulberry Street and like the little fake
lips give me some claims casino [ __ ]
broad look at her proposed that who's
talking about that theory that some
people believe that Leonardo da Vinci
that Mona Lisa was him in drag yeah that
it was a self-portrait who was it talent
said that when I was bringing up that's
right Carolyn said that the other day
yeah I've seen those things
what is it pull up a picture of him we
just what we never did we only pulled up
a picture of the photo we never pulled
up a picture of him and the photo that's
that's fascinating if that really was
the case if he just
I did - mm-hmm paint himself and dry
well they found all kinds of things in
that painting like like in her like like
her iris of her eyes there's actually
like like letters in there instead of
like really really tiny looking
extremely naughty [ __ ] demon comes
right out of there yeah ground you know
I had a dream that demons were real last
night I just remembered it I understand
a I had a dream where I was stupid about
them Steve almost 51 years old dreams of
dreams you know yeah that's a weak
[ __ ] thought I had a dream the other
day where I was the biggest dick in the
world like I was actually just being
really rude to everybody here's the
there's the drawing of him wow it's like
looking in a mirror yeah guys that's Oh
hmm
yeah you know you can kind of size
anything into anything yeah well I don't
know about that one yeah the head's a
little tall it might have gotten
confused with that you know the drawing
of the man in the circle and the square
yeah well you know maybe just imagined
yourself
as a woman I mean that's not necessarily
him and drag like I I've imagined that
before what would happen if I was born a
girl that same well I just stare at
myself naked in the mirror every day
look what I got a dress I could do just
a [ __ ] look at my duty easily with
Michelangelo he I always used to get
them confused Leonardo da Vinci Leonardo
da Vinci was the one that invented a
bunch of [ __ ] though yeah he was he was
the Renaissance man ya know he was also
kind of an engineer and he actually made
like or at least like you know like it
was like like a tank or anything like
lame as well he actually designed but he
designed like weapons of war also like
it wasn't just like airplanes or at
least gliders and helicopters and so
forth but ya know he McGahey
yeah look at all the different [ __ ] that
he came up with yeah that just tanked
Wow so you see a ship and you can see
like there's like kind of like like
holes for like guns all around it and
it's like wheels I'm not sure I'm not
sure they actually built it or not
that's like I kill everybody tank
they're so nondescript with where those
bullets are going they're going to 360
degrees
mmm spitting that thing around but ya
know he made like yeah he or she like
designed weapons up but no those were
canons it must have been right probably
that's what kind of didn't have really
guns back there yeah there there's in
that design yeah mm-hmm wow that is
crazy yeah no he was freaked he was a he
was red man what keep me hanging out
with that guy Yeah right just you know
try me like one of your french girls Oh
weird
no yeah yeah no yeah Michelangelo it's
the Sistine Chapel and he's actually
more of a sculptor than a painter funny
that crossbow you invented yeah but it's
like a giant one yeah looking at yeah
like one of the ones that they killed
the smile worth yeah look at that one
doesn't the multi gun the key almost
kind of invented like a machine gun like
the one just left of that yeah it's a
bunch of guns yeah it's a bunch of gun
barrels and it was like almost like a
like I mean it's like the first design
for a machine gun essentially shoots in
multiple directions looking again yeah I
I would really love
talk to an extraordinary person from
back then it must have been so different
hey give me some clams Casino Lee look
at this [ __ ] guy this airplane thing
yeah okay like a glider yeah like to
talk to Picasso or to talk to DaVinci or
any any of these people from exceptional
people from Ilocos it was like my
favorite Leachman comes to these
paintings and stuff but you know I I
heard it wasn't necessarily like you
know the the like coolest person to be
around kind of thing you ever see the
they were saying was the deal with them
I think I think he was an artist he was
very aware that he was Picasso look you
know like he was yeah he was already
like the most famous painter in the
world and he knew it kind of thing
hey he actually used to walk around he
didn't carry money or a wallet he just
carried like a pad so if he want to get
like a pack of cigarettes he could just
like it and there you go like that's so
he'd ever had to like pay for anything
because he was miserable [ __ ] yeah yeah
he comes in and and listen would you
accept that trade a pack of cigarettes
for a Picasso like yeah I'd take that
trade so are those around yeah he
actually has a lot of like little
sketches like all around they're
actually quite affordable at least when
in terms of owning a Picasso the key was
you know he was very prolific and just
look a lot of like ink drawings and so
forth
I mean there was the SNL sketch it was
like Lovitz was playing Picasso and it's
like but like he kind of I think you
went around kind of just doing anything
he wanted and he's like he's great
because I'm Picasso like you know and he
was just like just being in church
everybody
you mentioned love it's doing that
impression he was on news radio for a
whole season oh yeah yeah yeah after
Phil yeah he's good guy yeah I've always
look out whatever - my blood bumped into
him okay very very nice person yeah
really really sweet I ran into him at
I'm going to the with my buddy Seth
Green we went to the pee-wee Herman
Broadway show they had a bunch of years
back and yeah I ran into love it's like
they're backstage so it's like yeah just
like me Seth Green pee-wee Herman and
Jon Lovitz I'm like this is quite a
quite a little well get together this is
great this is a great table doing
stand-up for a while I don't think he's
doing it anymore because I don't see him
anymore
but a few years back he was doing a lot
of stand-up like he was he he was like
Bob he bought that John Lovitz comedy
club and Universal Universal is the
worst comedy club design of all time
well you know it's it's weird that he
was actually able to find a club that
was already named after him he was what
are the odds he bought used to the House
of Blues it was B beat no it was BB
King's club was BB King's Blues Club and
he turned it into the Jon Lovitz thing
and he was wow that was really
interesting I'm remembering that I saw
Sean Penn had that older brother that
big brother has died crisp ended I saw
that guy there play the harmonica
hammered went on stage and played look
at me I'm Chris been some weird
Hollywood thing and I was like wow
imagine that he's so famous you just
jump on stage and a blues club and play
the harmonica and everything happier
there I'm not weird yeah but I was
hoping he was maybe like Sean Penn
jumped up there and did like his type 5
but you would be on Mayer does stand-up
I've heard that very strange you know if
you're on stage here BB King's place
like if this is a stage there would be a
balcony but it would be above you like
way up there like right above you and so
like you'd have to look up to see the
people there what so they're basically
looking straight down on the top of your
head the worst idea for yeah design
mm-hmm yeah it's yeah it isn't when
you're seeing music you know you don't
necessarily have to be as connected to
the person's face I've been - I've been
to a place where I feel like you were
literally right over like the band and I
was gonna neat like watching the drummer
from overhead like it's kind of neat
yeah but ya know just like just watching
somebody with a bald spot on their head
that's really close yeah yeah I imagined
it was taller than that that's
interesting my memory is not that good
yeah you're getting older yeah yes yeah
well it's just it's just getting weird
because it's got too much [ __ ] in there
my brain has too much information she
tell you running at a room oh for sure
space on my hard drive for new things
yeah in like seventh grade I went to
seventh grade seventh grade I need that
anymore
who needs cursive am i right I wonder
why I stopped doing stand-up cuz he was
actually pretty funny and he was it was
weird because he was already famous and
yeah one of the things was like I I had
tried to encourage Phil Hartman to do
stand-up several times because he would
do stand-up where he would warm up for
the you know the crowd would be there
for the show
yeah and in between scenes there was
always some downtime and Phil would take
the warm-ups microphone and do bishhh
riff do like his Bill Clinton impression
this was during the whole Monica
Lewinsky scandal yeah he had like all
this material about Bill Clinton and
Monica mean his impressions were amazing
yeah yeah no he's like he's one of my
favorites of all time on that show yeah
he was amazing and so he was thinking
about what is this
Huntsville doing stand up look at that
[ __ ] look at those glasses is great get
14 likes Hey
I'm Jon Lovitz look at my legs
yeah so he's still doing it yeah good
for him good for him I said I've always
liked them great when I did SNL I think
was the first season where he had just
left I think because I did it pretty
much probably if I had to pick a season
I would have been that would have been
that one I did because he still had
Carvey and he still had you know Hartman
and Victoria Jackson like the whole kind
of group but forgot about Victoria
Jackson yeah she was [ __ ] hilarious
yeah yeah what happened to her she's a
hardcore conservative now what yeah huge
like right right winger she's put on a
little weight you know but I haven't we
all and yeah yeah no she's actually a
hardcore conservative now like she
shouts it from the mountaintops
what was she like when you met her she
was fine I mean listen was she
conservative back I was I was busy doing
the show kind of thing like that because
it's a lot of work and in the tour that
I had
I hate to do it without cue cards
because my father didn't wanted to use
KU cards so I'd like to memorize all
that stuff plus block plus plus the
skits I didn't even make him to the show
so I like I had to memorize like skits
that didn't even end up in it yeah she
is that dad yeah you know I like I said
I had a good memory and he didn't want
me reading you know because it you can
see it you can see when people are
reading oh yeah and he didn't want me
doing that soon Wow so new cue card but
also that means the other actors don't
you card for them either yeah of course
not you know oh they had like yeah no
I'm sure my father made a lot of friends
looking and like you know that that
weekend
well that's [ __ ] up like how can he
dictate whether or not the other actors
get cue cards I don't know good because
he could apparently he could Victoria
Jackson's a hardcore conservative so she
said she shouts it from the from the
mountaintops looking again active mmm
yeah so she was like you know so it was
that whole kind of group that kind of
late 80s group but then also it was a it
was Mike Myers second season I think you
know it was in the it was like you know
Schneider Sandler Chris Rock you know so
it was like that kind of overlap year so
I actually got like a really kind of
like really good group that lingo so
that was it's always weird when someone
from like a TV show gets really
political ya know well like Chuck
Woolery from the love oh I know that guy
is he's so [ __ ] crazy conservative oh
really nuts
yeah his Twitter feed I go to Twitter
feed every now and then just to see what
crazy old men conservatives are really
interested yeah how often does he use
the term big news you know yeah the Lib
Dems yeah yeah the Dems and the libs
they all trait
yeah he's guarantee he's got a like a
radio show like some like like all what
we make sense and one of those things
you know no nonsense
blunt force true what force truth true
yeah you damn liberals he's kind of more
like that sounds like a like a band from
Brooklyn look at it our concern for
crime but criminals would do bad things
no matter what find out more by
listening to blunt force truth
look at that it's hashtag BFT Wow he's a
he's pushing that you should listen to
some of that just for he he isn't hot
yeah I know right
you should also for James Woods old
dudes who want to put up giant gates so
they're gonna make in solar too what
happened actor Peter Fonda he's super
conservative to know isn't he I don't
know they're just Democrats to commit
voter fraud oh the opposite I think it's
the opposite yeah he's super super
Democrat turns feud with Trump into
activism bitter rosy all caps Trump
rallies his supporters are paid for
truth blunt force truth just look at
yeah look at that some some journalistic
integrity from Chuck Woolery that's his
whole thing his whole thing is that now
I think he lives in Texas or something
think he escaped California and all the
crazy libs yeah I will be right back and
- and - yeah yeah - and - I forget the
name of that show I remember I used to
like it that went on the game show
network then with all the boxes it was
like letters and stuff
[ __ ] I forget the name of it what's that
yeah yeah I only remember the love
connection I had like ten made the game
show network yeah like when that like
launched look yeah I mean like yeah we
can get we can get Chuck Woolery I'll go
on if you let me talk about the damn
libs yeah yeah exactly
you know you know Trebek and you know it
was busy look you know he's already busy
on his own thing but we can get willory
yeah mm-hmm how weird what was the guy
scrabble or lingo - lingo there we go
welcome back I've got a tie and cue
cards yeah okay that cow what is it it's
a nice oh look at that look at those two
dorks so much judgment
oh yeah exactly I just kind of need to
pee yeah go pee marry cool don't worry
about we live yeah
it doesn't matter I'm gonna go guys dude
we'll talk some [ __ ] about Chuck Woolery
naturally stoned did a show called
naturally stone come on get the [ __ ] out
of here
he is a what a song called naturally
stoned Oh what is this
naturally stoned an American reality
television show that starred American
game show host Chuck Woolery six
episodes aired in game show network in
2003 between June 15th and July 27
series centered around Woolery and his
family specifically his personal life
and his work as a host of gain strong
networks original game show lingo the
show placed strain on both Woolery
workload and his marriage it says the
series titles derived from his top 40
song from his band the avant-garde what
he had a what what that [ __ ] what he had
a band Chuck Woolery had man psychedelic
pop group get 1967 [ __ ] I gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here you gotta find that
song a psychedelic pop group oh my
goodness Chuck naturally stoned
psychedelics but natural sight he had a
pop band yes yes yes it was it was like
a Mamas and the Papas esque kind of like
60s like kind of song I think he
probably was trying to do it on the
natch though okay let's listen to some
of this oh yeah oh yeah
that's him right there naturally stoned
honey and gall will get pulled so the
people listen on YouTube you got to go
Google avant-garde naturally stoned the
people that are listening on you know
Google Play and iTunes and all that [ __ ]
you can hear this yeah I know this is
very like incense and peppermint's kind
of sound terrible mm-hmm like yeah okay
just got terrible keep going oh my god
sounds groovy man yeah
actually stoned you still naturally
stoned and there's Chuck Wow look at
Chuck up front we'll be right back in
two and two
if you hit two and two he's got wooden
beads on that wooden beads around his
neck - yeah they both do look guys we
got beads on we're cool feel like I'm at
that party like I'm Haight Ashbury or
something like that and you know I want
to fly late 60s the guy in the back with
his hand on his hip see what the [ __ ]
he's up to these days Pat Sajak honey
and all like what is that I think it's
the name of the album oh that's the name
of the album oh I don't know actually
ignores probably the b-side Elkin Bubba
Fowler Elkins got a duck hunting show on
the Sportsman's Channel now I'm kidding
what is he doing this there's a Leonard
Cohen thing yeah the avant-garde how
strange
yes I think blunt-force truth is a
better name for a band than the
avant-garde yeah it is right yet tonight
at the pit blunt-force what are weird
Dean for the show blunt-force truth
spitting hot truth - spit hot fire wake
up kids I always liked that I always
loved that line from
Chappell was like you know I spit hot
fire there's like a zip there's cold
buyer hot fire right you're in the cold
fusion yeah that's us so strange that
the whole thing that he was in a band
yep the avant-garde - gosh that is so
like the of that era it's so funny when
those old dudes get like real over from
1974 look at that chick burns very Jay
Leno asking that phone yeah look at him
here
give me some volume can we hear him sing
here he goes he definitely has a nice
voice hmm oh yeah oh I've heard this
song before this is a cover this is a
cover you make me so very happy yeah
there's the cover okay kill this honey
how do ya how do you go from the
avant-garde to like yeah like hosting
like you know well because dating game
or whatever because this isn't good yeah
that's a weird transition well he's a
handsome guy probably good talker and
yeah his agent was like Chuck Chuck
Chuck I'm telling you the moon the music
is not anything good yeah hosting I'm
gonna give you the blunt-force truth
yeah same showers like I like that
phrase you've got a look you take a look
Chuck the look is game show host you got
it you get you have it listen how about
you being on the game show network what
do you think about that fella does
anyone actually ever like aspire to be a
game show host
oh for sure I know I know I know like
you know but like when you're a kid you
know I mean like you want to be an
astronaut or whatever got to be someone
who's like watches prices that Zack
Morris from Saved by the Bell
he wanted to be a game show host yeah
he's not a real person I know I'm just
saying I am I'm just making conversation
[ __ ] dream you just shattered
mock my dream no I was just [ __ ] I was
asking a question as a legit question
like you know like yeah do people aspire
to be
game show host yeah for sure I know in
the UK like host is a thing that people
aspire to be lacrosse okay ask somebody
what do you do is I host I'm like was
that team that they get they usually got
panelist on like a show television
presenter yeah
presenter exactly yes yes apresenta
that song actually gave them that was so
are so much of a hit that they were a
one-hit wonder then and he had to become
a truck driver a simplement supplement
his income he then signed on as a solo
artist had five more songs on his own
didn't obviously work out that well then
he became the first host wheel of
fortune in 1975 it's great so how long
did he do it for six years wheel of
fortune for six years geez what you're
doing start 75 so it was a year after
that after that thing we just watched
so was it one year later I hope you
still had that hair that mean of hair
does I think and those yeah and there's
the salt pepper yeah there's a little
like the sideburns the mutton chops
old-school ones go done your job Valerie
dispute and then go straight to say Jack
imagine a [ __ ] turns it on still on
the area [ __ ] that's the blunt force I
have regrets
that's that truth maybe you didn't want
to do it anymore maybe that's what it
was contract negotiations but anyone
straighten to like the dating game or
whatever show get to see chicks I guess
so they're trying to get laid yeah I
guess some said you got you got chicks
and dudes trying to get laid yeah your
facilitators and putting love together I
mean you know got the most action was
richard dawson family feud oh yeah he
always kissed every lady on the list
even like the ones that were underage
did you ever see that movie with uh
think of speech is he gonna richard
dawson
the guy who was in Hogan's Heroes with
him what was that [ __ ] movie Oh like
the music's about that gets nuts super 8
or one of those it's not that
the movie were whoo what was that guy's
name I don't know okay he was apparently
he was the guy was the star of Hogan's
Heroes and they just became the freak of
the week he's got a mop which homemade
porno [ __ ] all the time that's all he
did that's all he did yeah yeah they
think the guy he did porn with killed
him is I believe his murder was never
saw but there was some sort of
extenuating circumstances that connected
his his porn buddy
the guy was in the movie I think they
maybe that was what they implied in the
movie I think that was what it was well
if it was in a movie it has to be true
uh-huh yeah you know it they don't ever
lie man true crime that's the thing
about movies when they do a story about
your life they don't change [ __ ] and hit
but no they literally get every word
right otherwise they would lose
credibility mmhmm yeah yeah this there's
movies where they change [ __ ] you're
like why did you change that mm-hmm like
they just decide like his historical
things because I always say oh it's
creative license or like we have to
condense things because a person's life
is like you know so long and things like
that do you remember that movie about
the movie with it was with
what's-his-name from the office well yes
Steve Carell he played that yeah we're
both thinking the same thing I was just
waiting to get the description I was
gonna say exact now that that movie is
based on two very famous wrestlers Dave
Schultz and Mark Schultz and in the
movie they put a ton of [ __ ] in
there yeah and don't mean a lot of it
mark was furious when the mat remember
reading that yeah and you know you want
a crazy wild Twitter storm but then
after that like the end of the movie he
there's a historic moment in that in
that movie that they just completely
made up like he fought this guy named
Big Daddy Goodrich in the UFC I mean
it's it sports history it sounds like
that sounds like a WWE wrestler I know
it does could have been a WWE wrestler
but uh Big Daddy Goodrich who's you know
really a pioneer in MMA fighting was
this big [ __ ] Jack black guy who wore
aggie he wore like a traditional
karate gear into the Octagon in the
movie they have him fighting a white guy
a Russian guy whitewashing they just
decided they don't want to see why guys
yes America we have we had to fight the
Russians I was like why would you change
the race and the name of the guy he
fought yeah that seems like weird and
like petty almost no you know it's just
weird it's just greasy producers who
think they're smart you've been around
them you know those [ __ ] I have no idea
what you're talking about tell me more
they you know they just decide they're
smarter than everybody and they know
better they know how to change history
and make it make it a better show yeah
you know we were it was the 80s ole I
guess it has to be against a Russian
kind of thing wasn't Haiti's well I'm
saying it takes place isn't it please no
Jews in the 90s noise yeah it was I
think you fought in 1995 I know when
Kurt Angle like I know trained in that
facility the the Fox catcher he's
talking about that how crazy that guy
was just decided to set up some
wrestling things so you get like weird
with these dudes yeah exactly when a
bunch of some strong sweaty men like
rubbing up against each other it's I bet
you those Rhett loos like wrestlers like
when they're training I bet you whoever
they're training with knows their body
better than their wives you know it's a
really intimate thing I mean like how
could you they know every curve of their
trainee grip around your waist it is an
intimate sport yeah remember when he was
like in the movie Steve Carell was so
good in that movie I loved him in that
yeah not he played that creep so well he
played it like a guy who's like a loose
cannon yeah creepy weird he lives can
small ya know the way he kind of like
his movements and his speech like it was
it was good it was good
remember when he was well liked he
decided he was gonna coach
coach the wrestlers and show them how to
do certain moves and everybody just sort
of tolerated and yeah let him have this
one no strain but what a great scene but
here's the thing like that that scene
was so good but now I know you lied at
the end so I know you lied at the end of
the movie so now I go well did you make
up that scene it starts losing
credibility when I did watch I did watch
a doc about that I think there's a 34:30
about the Foxcatcher Institute yeah
whatever it was there was a lot of
footage on that guy in corral yeah
[ __ ] nailed yeah yep on that on
Department yeah yeah yeah what a strange
strange guy that guy was em hmm
mr. DuPont it's just that's an
unfortunate thing about those wrestlers
like there's no real professional venue
other than fighting if they want to go
into MMA and he was a coach at Brigham
Young Mark Schultz was and he just he
fought one time in the UFC and then just
stayed they I don't think they wanted
him doing it I think that was a part of
the dispute is his coach up believe it
was Brigham Young his uh the school that
he was coaching for was like listen you
want a coach here you can't be caged
right especially like early like MMA was
not respected at all you know I remember
John McCain trying to like in again like
it was a blood sport and he you know
what that was about that was about
Budweiser because Budweiser sponsored
boxing and MMA was doing very well with
pay-per-view back then and they wanted
to stop it in his tracks and Budweiser
was a big part of that and Budweiser who
sort of got behind him yeah that's all
greasy yeah I mean the boxing world is
so greasy cuz I'm a fight fan at least
like boxing I was kind of like always
kind of raised that way like I do follow
it I've only recently kind of gotten
into like the MMA and kind of stuff look
I've gone to some shows they're going to
see any sporting event is always great
live looking in you go to live boxing
matches so I haven't in a while but yeah
especially I used to look I used to go
to like I saw Holyfield more one vision
oh yeah I saw Holyfield bo1 like things
like that like yeah during that kind of
peak you know yeah like that was that
90s era boys yeah did a lot of those but
uh those were great but that stuff is so
greasy you know I remember the first
Holyfield Lewis like that how then in a
draw so they could you
double up their money and stuff remember
that fight I don't remember how I feel
versus Lois at all yeah they fell twice
did Lois win the first time no draw one
draw the for the shitty of one yeah yeah
yeah
you know losers it was it was a great
leg boxer but at the same time I just
remember being driven nuts like where he
was like where is like belt I'm up to
here like it was like way past his belly
button he's 40 he's already like six six
already and it's kind of like yeah like
he's he's wearing that thing too high
look you know like he's getting away
with murder
yeah yeah it should have you know yeah
I'm surprised you got away with that you
know that that equipment but both most
referees will tell you you can hit him
here yeah yeah but you know like I said
it was kind of just it felt like an
unfair advantage especially for a guy
who was like like I said six six we're
good against already enormous yeah
exactly like you know he's so it's even
higher than normal and that would be a
big target for somebody who's like only
legs you know so you follow boxing today
though yeah yeah I'm really looking
forward I want to see wilder versus
Joshua look that's what I want to see
yeah take some fury though like he's
kind of back in the ring like I said
fewer might [ __ ] them all up that's a
problem - they're all big guys today are
big guys but Tyson Fury looks [ __ ]
fantastic there's some footage on his
Instagram of him doing pad work you know
and he's fighting really soon he just
bought like a warm-up kind of like you
know some journeyman but it's got about
coming up
well Tyson does I think I think it just
happened
like here or somebody or does he have
another one coming think he's got it I'm
pretty sure he's got another one I'm a
big Deontay Wilder fan I am - yeah like
it just is wild man yeah exit unorthodox
and like man the way he [ __ ] slugs
look Jesus Christ this is vicious power
oh yeah yeah I watch the highlight reels
and just like yeah I mean it's give that
guy a seizure there was that one where
the boom the guy's glancing just like
he's like a flopping around like a fish
there's like Jesus Christ he heads
[ __ ] hard because he's like six seven
he's a big dude he is long to like
create leverage smashes right boom yeah
that the recent one yeah yeah that was
AK from like was losing that fight I
stopped Ortiz I thought it showed out
like yeah it showed that like he's got
like he's got heart he's got a pretty
okay chin you know like that he knows
how to recover who's your favorite
fighter to watch
right now and yeah I said I really do
love watching Wilder like right now
triple G's good yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
he's he's look at like he's might be
like an old-timer kind of thing yeah
look how good this guy looks six foot
nine give me some volume on this I could
hear this he's thick too but he's he's
like showing how slick he is cuz yes
he's not just big he's big and long but
here he toys he toyed with Klitschko
yeah man
dude he's [ __ ] good and he gives
people fits yeah the new rumors is
supposed to be wilder versus fury like
now the Joshua like stalks him like you
know not happening well yeah
Tyson Fury could [ __ ] up that whole
thing man
so it's the 18th of August and they're
both a little unorthodox too so would be
actually interesting to see like him
square off with Wilder [ __ ] yeah yeah
both super-long yeah that would be very
interesting but I only be like the first
time leathers fighting somebody is
bigger than him not just bigger but
super-slick he's gonna give him fits yep
yep I mean look Wilder can knock out
anybody but Tyson Fury he he'll give you
fits mmm guys cuz while there is like
what like 3700 with 36 knockouts just
once
it's crazy it's a crazy record yep it's
it's Tyson esque like young Tyson hasn't
but they're completely different
fighters yeah young Jason was just so
tight and like you know like and while
there's he puts his hands down yeah he
wants to counterpunch like you know
that's his whole thing what's
interesting is people still don't
believe in him like I had heard that the
Joshua fight like I would think that
that would be like a pretty evenly
matched fight people like no no like
Joshua's heads you know heads above
everybody else it's like you know I'm
not so sure look you know you take out
some good challenges though I mean like
Joshua can go he's amazing yeah don't
get me wrong but he got knocked down by
Klitschko Tyson Fury toured with clich
guy putting his hands behind his back
and maybe it was not the same as
prepared a Klitschko you know miters are
different for everybody and clutch goes
like yet like aging obviously yes at
that point yeah but I just think that
that style that Tyson Fury style avoid
that [ __ ] like measles mmm-hmm get away
ya know
the reason why Joshua doesn't want to
fight while their fury yeah good because
also he is the top draw right now look
he can sell out like you know like forty
fifty thousand in his home country
whereas like Wilder like in his home
state you fights a lot in Alabama like
it's like ten thousand or something like
that like you know so Josh was a bigger
draw well he's becoming I think Wilders
becoming a bigger draw nationally
mmm-hmm now but it's it I think that's
also one of the things with boxing is
like they're always trying to figure out
like when do we make this fight do we
make it now or do we wait a couple of
months let me see two undefeated
champions my teacher like that doesn't
really happen that often especially in
the heavyweight division like something
that's like really special someone could
[ __ ] up and lose yeah exactly exactly as
made me whether Pacquiao all over again
where it's like it happened but it
happened too late right exactly so stay
the [ __ ] away from Tyson Fury kids what
do you think about the the mcgregor
mayweather like fight it went he would
did much better than I thought he's
gonna get me to but I think that
Mayweather was probably wanting to wear
him out and so allowed him to express
but he did catch Mayweather with a very
clean left he was rapid punching the
whole trend that was driving me insane
just kept on just punching the back of
his head like you don't surprise those
hammerfist yes exactly look you can't do
that look you know I'm surprised like
the ref like let him get away with
murder but trade him I think you wanted
to frustrate me weather and get
Mayweather to try to start open up yeah
cuz that because like Mayweather his
defense is like super tight and like no
he came in there like Mayweather fought
a perfect kind of fight he's like just
I'm gonna let this guy gas himself out
and that's exactly what he did well
because when a knockout artist but he
knocked him out you know he definitely
stopped him but Conor's not known for
his cardio yeah he's a fast twitch guy
yeah I think it was when they opened up
the books for that fight it was a
thousand to one from McGregor to win by
decision I almost put a grand on that
just anyway just on principle I just
want I just want a million dollars
you know one but I could just sit there
and I turn to my friends like I think I
just want a million dollars
do you know crazy that would be to win a
million dollars we're putting down a
thousand dollar bet some crazy but those
those bets are nuts like will it make it
out of the first round well yeah yeah by
decision they even have like
disqualification bets
yeah yeah like exactly like yeah I used
to play a lot of cards and I love prop
bets just like you know like look in
that moment it's like I bet you like I
can guess within you know a hundred
dollars how many chips are in front of
you right now like you know like that
kind of stuff for like you know or it's
like all right like you know give me you
know give me a you know one in ten
chance you pull out a dollar bill from
your pocket and whatever the last number
is like if I get it right
you know you can pay me ten to one oh
just like weird prop bets like people
like like big like players like kind of
go nuts with that kind of stuff well
gambling junkies do right yeah exam look
I remember us playing cards at this one
Club and this guy just was sports
betting like crazy even but now it's
like you know like 2:00 in the morning
3:00 in the morning and he's looking
down he goes does anyone know anything
about cricket I was like that was the
only game that was going on there's a
cricket game in India and he was like
yeah I'm gonna like late I'm like dude
you actually have a problem like that's
like you know yeah like you have to like
like that's a problem you're betting on
cricket it's 2:00 in the morning anyone
know anything about cricket
well that's the crazy thing about those
sports book so you look up and watch
that [ __ ] yeah like here's a bunch of
horses yeah
who's gonna win I've actually I have a
buddy who does a like Italy's into the
races and some like that and like he
streams it from my calling it is kind of
fun listen yeah it's kind of like but
you kind of just range mele like just
like oh sure number eight like it was
like you know come on eight I knew a guy
who got banned for life from chariot
races for trying to rig a race because
he was his his horses winning and his
horse wasn't supposed to win this is
literally standing up pulling back on
the reins as his horse was winning [ __ ]
off his name was George the Greek that
supposed to call Wow
guy from a pool hall in White Plains New
York yeah the Greek is like a tiny
there's because it was Jimmy the Greek
back in the day yeah he was always
trying to like he was telling us was
it's a little vape he was always telling
us that uh he was gonna win the lawsuit
I got Kunstler yeah counselor was his
lawyer
I got consular working on the case got
this [ __ ] thing I got him locked down
Chariot Racing how do you get into
chariot racing duel again I mean
obviously you need like you know okay
look if you're if it's a swirl okay but
like how do you like do you like like
fall into how do you fall into that line
of work or again like when you're a kid
you are going I grow up I want to be a
chariot racer out of that movie with
Kirk Douglas in the chair yeah exactly
just look at you imagine himself with a
bow and arrow in the back you know yeah
those crazy wrist plates exactly listen
Greaves you know yeah crazy movie
because if you look at the difference do
you like Spartacus and 300 right yeah
you look at Spartacus they had like
normal bodies like you guys that just
ate toast and you know he didn't work
out back in like the Roman days like I
would I was I'd be considered tall I'm 5
7 like you know like a lot of those
soldiers like you know like likes in
Spartans and Roman food they were like 5
5 because they probably know food yeah
there was like there was a lot of you
know like yeah I was gonna say
malnutrition but that was kinda like it
wasn't straight malnutrition it just
wasn't good nutrition like anything a
lot of like a like salt pork yeah you
know like that could I think a lot of
like weird flatbreads
you know not a lot of not a lot of green
there not a lot of greens you know a lot
of just grain and salted beef it was
probably really hard to get good food
back then like as you're as you're
growing up you probably were always
mounted nourished and no one was fat
either right it's very rare people yeah
people were rarely fat well that's why
it's like a like a fat lady like was
considered like really really sexy
because it showed that she was well that
she's got some cash exactly yeah that's
like the Aphrodite like in Suffolk that
it's all very very curvy yeah yeah they
went through a whole era where those
rubenesque women yeah every desk yeah
that was the thing that's what everybody
wanted yeah yeah
want to give me a big guy yeah man some
some cushion for the pushing now we're
in danger right now we're treading in
dangerous waters even talking about that
I know take me to Kirk Douglas find Kirk
Douglas and Spartacus comparing them
sporadic sporadic sporadic 'it's when
you were in Paris did you know this oh
there is yeah look at that Doug's a guy
who's literally never swung a sword yeah
he looks he looks here he only looks old
there oh yeah he was well I bet he was
probably in his 30s because people back
then just aged worse yeah they just I
don't know what the [ __ ] it was going on
that just a didn't age good it is a is
that is the liquor and you know mm-hmm
yeah but you smoke cigarettes and you
look fantastic
you look great I agree what is it yeah
let's take a guess let's take guess how
old he was
during Spartacus it was I think he was a
hair under 40 hmm I think you're right I
would go 37 what is he
44 kind of looks like 44
yeah not at today's 44 yeah like Daniel
Craig's jacked his [ __ ] he's probably
like 44 mm-hm how old's Daniel Craig
right now
James Bond doesn't he have like some
like crow's feet or whatever 50/50
jacked
really just 50 right [ __ ] oh
look at that it's looking good
how old are you 50 look at you look at
you you're big dude look at that
jacked mm-hmm you're a big dude but I
could take you whoa that looks like
[ __ ] James Bond me not all these
other [ __ ] he's my all-time favorite
James Bond like far that's a real James
Bond yeah I know I like his like yeah a
lot is steely resolve my other favorite
James Bond is a potential James Bond
adavi the James Bond yet it's Idris Elba
address Elba and because white people
are mad
yeah it's like fantastic for moving they
got like maybe Jordan it's like everyone
just calm down
look at that right there oh good lord
let his body look at that barf
look at that he's already kind of got a
little little look he's got the
beginning of man tits yeah I mean he's
not bad it's better than my fat he
doesn't look like a guy who fought with
a [ __ ] sword for a living yeah but
that's how they that's probably close er
like more accurate to what you know what
actual like Romans and you know not if
they were actual gladiator there an
actual gladiator they had to swing
swords around look at that arm
come on then arm ain't carrying no
swords just lean muscles lean muscle
guys got some veins coming out bro he's
jacked but yeah this is Kubrick people
who people always forget yes confirm
that but yeah that's a man yeah I
apparently hated it too like you yeah he
hated the movie yeah it's probably one
of those things you had to do yeah 60
yeah geez god I loved his movies yeah
yeah no this is actually one of the
weaker ones really you ever read The
Shining no it's really interesting
different Stephen King did not like it
yeah not like the movie because they did
the TV movie yes like in the early 2000s
even weddings Steven Weber yeah and he
just decided that you know like Kubrick
had made Jack Nicholson crazy already
yeah and he didn't like that yeah and he
wanted a guy that was turned crazy by
the house yeah yeah yeah but how the
[ __ ] you gonna do that in a two-hour
movie you know what's not scary
hedges you know there's a thing is like
it probably like you know I bet you if
you know you read it or whatever
it's probably seems creepy like when
he's like talking about how the hedges
are moving when he's not looking in
something that but when you physically
see it it's not scary at all
you don't I mean like yeah like it's
just like things like that like just the
thing to really translate but it worked
in the book the books amazing the books
really it's a big-ass book - it's a
Stephen King I mean
I think it's a big-ass book yeah there's
a Mesa confusing it was a The Dark Tower
series there's also the stand is really
thick yeah that's a dictionary
paperweight he was I mean it still is
but so [ __ ] pearl if there's a thing
with the at the mazes it's like yeah
like the mesas keeps on kind of like
changing like the one the one that you
see in the model there and the one that
exists and there's also a map on the
outside of it all three of those are
different bushes and get a look from the
top I think it's like kind of more like
stems I don't think they're like thick
branches just hack your way through just
walk straight yeah that's true spirit of
bushes what are you scared of the
moisture come on
well the hedges that are moving you know
yeah in the book so monsters mm-hmm yeah
they're it's kind of like you know these
like like Edward Scissorhands
esque like kind of like you know it's a
kid yeah it's like and then it's like oh
it's moving when you're not looking like
oh that's an adorable cat hedge that um
that place that wood that's supposed to
be the esses park is that what it's
supposed to be that area was supposed to
be somewhere in Colorado that's like
that yeah I mean I think that's where
they filmed it or at least the you know
the outdoor some of it and I think they
filmed some of it also in upstate New
York yeah yeah like yeah but it look in
and then get like a studio I think I
think was from London usually Kubrick
worked in out of London but yeah the
Overlook Hotel there we go
yes yeah it actually is like it's not
called the Overlook in real life but
yeah it's in Colorado yeah that was a
[ __ ] great movie yeah so creepy and
weird so many of him her eyes wide shut
that was another one yeah that's and
that's his last movie yeah a lot of
people didn't like that one I thought
that was fast
yeah I you know I'm a little soft on it
I released when it comes to like I mean
it's still great right I put it lower on
my Kubrick
yeah Clockwork Orange 2001 I mean like
it again you name it
you know it during his spare time he
used to do complex mathematics that
sounds about right yeah it was like
genius yeah he's a archives in I think
it's in London but there's actually
disdaining Kubrick like library and you
can kind of go through his scripts and
his notes and all kind of stuff look you
know there's some you know like a whole
like archive but it supposed to be kind
of pretty neat
you self over making movies like
producing or directing maybe writing if
it's you know piques my fancy kind of
thing if it piques my fancy mm-hmm I'd
be open to doing so make that you know
like a matter of what kind of the right
kind of thing run timing and so forth
yeah like right now wouldn't be ideal
but like you know a year from now like
yeah I probably might be a little freer
like that kind of thing you know yeah
like you know hopefully the company will
be moving on it so and buy that kind of
thing okay here's something I want to
ask you about Paris this is one thing
that I was only there for a short period
of time but one things I was shocked
stuck shocked by shocked
is that all those people are eating a
bread and they're all eating cheese and
wine and no one's fat yeah what the [ __ ]
is that again it's kind of the way that
you couldn't eat how you kind of thought
you know you have a light breakfast but
a heavy dinner I think that has to do
with it and also you can't call yourself
a boulangerie
like a bakery unless you make everything
from scratch like so everything's made
from scratch
and like the thing is is that like
you're like baguette will be stale in 24
hours same thing with the croissants
like there's no preservatives and
anything let's think like all out in
general out there like all your food
spoils faster lucky in your fridge not
because like yeah it's it's you know
like it's fresh there's no hormones and
things roads he was an oncologist from
Paris and he lived in America and he
went back to France and brought back
cheese because the cheese that he could
get over there was not homogenized or
pasteurized and literally illegal here
yeah so he would have to tuck it in his
carry-on or in his checked luggage and
just hope that no one would check the
wheel of cheese excuse me sir when he
served it to us it was like precious
yeah this precious cheese I mean they
make raw cheese in American now but it's
like specific and like yeah like you
have to like you know it's like it's
Tiki kind of thing very boutique you
know niche kind of thing ya know see
thing would they like their eggs if they
don't refrigerate their eggs over there
because it's done in a different kind of
process like I think I forget what it is
that I get from my chickens you don't I
don't refer
yeah you know after a while no you can
wash them but I think in America it's I
think we like I think it's like we I
think we like like like hit him with it
like super hot water there's a different
process than they have in Europe so in
general you're not supposed to
refrigerator eggs there we're in the
States you are supposed to hmm and just
a different it's a different process of
how things are done yeah the
preservative thing makes a lot of sense
yes our lives and I think there's also
there's also different [ __ ] that's in in
wheat and there's different kinds of
wheat they have heirloom wheat with it's
like older wheat before you know we
started messing with it yeah and they
also they're their cattle and things
like that
it's a grass-fed whereas in the states
it's corn-fed right and also I just
noticed like in general out there like I
was eating less red meat you have a lot
more chicken and a lot of pig lots of
ham but you know that kind of thing ham
is a very lucky man well it's dried or
whatever looking at yeah and just cured
legs yeah I just take that thin slice
I'm actually going they're going back in
a couple of days so yeah you know really
Nancy because I'm going out to Berlin
I'm doing this thing it's called the
people festival look out there and so
I'm gonna do something like hang out
with some friends I know like a good
label fest it's called the people
festival it means a music fest
and I know like a good like twelve or
twenty like of the acts girl I couldn't
like they're like my friends and stuff
you know so get to like go to Berlin and
I'm gonna be like the roving reporter
pretty much yeah I found myself you know
something to do what about there yeah
it's gonna be like podcasting and so
forth because there's a lot of like yeah
there's a lot of like cool musicians
doing it so oh that's cool so yeah it's
a so good like I'm kind of like fine
from LA to New York spending the night
because I hate taking like super long
flights and then New York to Paris yeah
and then you then you know Paris to
Berlin you know even when you do that
yes I travel at my whim I should have a
Manhattan in my hand like haha Oh shall
we book you a straight flight to Europe
no no of course yeah that's too much
time in the air I like to puddle jump I
want to go to New York I'll go to New
York
perhaps I'll shop
perhaps a shop in Paris in power II go
to a cafe mm-hmm maybe I'll take the the
channel to London just for a day trip
I've arrived a fantastic t-shirt shop
and I love now one of the things that
people were in America that don't go to
Paris or worried about it's like people
hear horror stories about the
immigration nightmare in Paris and that
Paris is somehow another turning into
this criminal cesspool because of all
these immigrants and it's very dangerous
there now hence those shootings that you
heard about and the you know it is
actually one of the most ethnically
diverse cities in all of like Europe
like I was actually like you know um you
know you you see more like black people
and like the first five minutes of being
there than you do in the whole of like
Oslo or lik Berlin or something like
that ya know it's it is like kind of its
culturally and ethnically like diverse
you know when it comes to all this like
shootings and things like that
they're guilty of being landlocked you
know the UK can kind of control the the
you know the flow of traffic
you know people kind of coming in and
out because they're an island nation
where it's like with the kind of open
borders but that you can you know you
can buy a gun in Greece and take the
train you know like all the way over
look you know especially when it comes
like the old uh was the like the Balkans
or whatever like you know there's a lot
of leftover soviet-era like coalition of
coughs that's why they always have like
a these Russian made like guns and so
forth and yeah like that's what I mean
if it's easier for so you know somewhere
like the UK to like lock off the
reporters or at least have like you know
where is France it's like they said it's
guilty of being landlocked essentially
the you know these more difficult to
secure is that the blunt-force truth yes
blood force truth PFT and that's the BFT
yeah they people should start using that
the PFT has the hashtag PFT PFT PFT
coming your way it's like delicious but
they the the the big fear like the one
thing that people were terrified of was
that this was going to happen to the
rest of Europe that like what's happened
to Paris in Paris is falling apart and
you can go through
the ghetto areas in Paris and you know
there was a someone filmed something
where a Jewish man walked through these
Muslim ghettos and they're screaming out
I'm all these anti-semitic things and I
have not seen that but you know my
neighborhoods are only a couple blocks
away from like the Jewish kind of
neighborhoods that's good spot to live
it was good to live near the Jewish folk
together yeah I'm gonna New Yorker so
I'm like I'm already half Jewish you
know house in New York recently we were
in Brooklyn and I was with Ari my friend
Ari who grew up Orthodox Jew and he took
us through this neighborhood where they
have like the crazy frisbee fur hats on
the curls and the pace mmm in the the
[ __ ] the yarn hanging off their belt
yeah we're chin and you know who's
basically saying like these people like
they are here but they're not here like
they don't know what the [ __ ] is going
on they have no idea who Kim Kardashian
is yeah they don't listen to any of the
music they all stick together they
intermarry the Marian cider community if
they get married young in the cab yeah
and it's so interesting seeing them all
walk and they've sang through the sheets
you know that some of them do right yeah
citic though yes just a whole way so I
think just throw a sheet over and just
you know just perfectly frame the vagina
right there I'll take care of it from
here they don't want to touch naked
women right is up their ideas yeah I
think it's a modesty kind of thing no
we're kind of like tradition okay I do
that at home just for fun yeah honey why
are these where their holes in other
sheets gosh she just wants this Jesus
was a Jew it's okay okay so like this
this community that we were driving
through is massive like Brooklyn yeah I
was gonna say Brooklyn like kind of in
the southern kind of a massive community
yeah I didn't know how big Brooklyn was
yeah it's it's big it's [ __ ] huge
it really is yeah it's kind of like
you're talking about the neighborhood
that kind of like north of Red Hook but
right there on the river because I but I
walked from my place and low
Manhattan all the way down to like Red
Hook like one day and it was a long it'd
take like maybe about an hour an hour
ish but it yeah I'm I work I walk at a
New York pace you must have been
sprinting yeah I'm uh
I walk into New York base Walker that
choice if you run seven miles an hour
that's like a fairly good clip it's
gotta be more than seven miles um no no
no it's not look you're just understand
the whole of Manhattan is I think it's
like 14 miles it's a 14 by 4 and I'm
already living like in the southern part
yeah yeah it's probably I don't know
like about 3 3 miles yeah that 3 miles I
walk in about 3 to 4 miles an hour one
of the guys that was there with us the
guy who was driving us was telling us
how Brooklyn is just overwhelmed with
building construction apartment
buildings now and everyone's moving out
of Manhattan and into Brooklyn yeah it's
it's because the thing about Manhattan
is that it's finite right look you know
so the only way like hey you can build
upwards but you can only do that so much
and so it a lot of people are getting
like displaced like you have to have
enough money just to stay on the island
of Manhattan and even people like that
are getting displaced then like yeah
they it's Brooklyn Queens etcetera
Hoboken the people that I know that live
in Manhattan always have this thought in
their head that one day they might live
in LA yeah even Bourdain was saying
sometimes I think about it I think about
the weather and I know there's a lot of
good things about LA a lot of nice
places LA I lived here for the better
part of eight years like my early 20s
and stuff and it's a you know I mean it
makes you soft I mean like it because it
yeah I think just like with the weather
and things like that and it's also like
yeah that leisurely kind of like kind of
thing like there's not a lot of drinking
it's a lot more smoking we've just
because like everyone has to drive you
know some nobody like you know so
everyone's just like um it would buy so
fast because there's no seasons right
it's all the same so I blinked it was
like wait I've been living here for five
years look I'm from New York it's like
we have we have lucky summer winter
winters long it's one of the few like
major cities like where you have a
hundred degree weather shift in one year
it could be a hundred degrees and later
that you can be zero degrees yeah that's
true that's interesting so it's kind of
like it's kind of a harsh kind of
climate a little bit in the summer is
there like suck
cuz it's just the humidity it just
sticks to you and it's smelly look at me
I'm not a huge fan of New York in the
summer yeah it gets very pissed like yes
yes it's sticky at 60 your hair like
I've never lived in the city though you
know and I might have missed my shot
because you know now I'm married and
kids and the whole deal and I'm so sorry
and a stand-up comedian it's a lot of
the the only thing that we could
possibly make me live there was that
like I could do stand-up there very easy
yeah yeah you know there's a lot of like
yeah
well I think the island of Manhattan
only has like six of them technically
it's like five or six six wha
comedy clubs I couldn't think it's not
for sex
yeah there's got to be more than that I
don't know look it's because I have a
buddy who's the seller has two clubs
there's danger fields there's Caroline's
there's uh Eastvale comedy club this my
buddy opened up one in like 2010 oh
we're ready at 7:00
yeah well he opened up one like in about
like 2010 or something done he was
talking about he goes actually there's
not yeah I mean he was actually you said
like yeah it goes when I opened up there
was only like six you know like he was
like the seventh one or some like that
really it's surprising at least on the
island of Manhattan itself there's not
as many comedy clubs as you'd think
do you know even though it's a mecca in
the turn of the century night the 19th
to the 18th to the 19th to the 20th
century there was a thousand or close to
a thousand billiard halls Manhattan oh
geez yeah yeah no no that's what men did
before video games and pretty much and
that's like when men didn't want to have
families they the match bachelor life
would they would live in these pool play
billiards yeah gamble mm-hmm and a smoky
smoky pool hall no there's I just play a
lot of pool of its voice oh yeah there's
actually not a lot of billiard clubs
there anymore look at you I mean I'm
saying they do exist but like you know
there's like only us like I had a
smattering of them this bowling alley is
like there's only yes yeah
yeah I think even like Bowman were like
moved like kind of thing look into that
was the trendy spot this is gonna be
like croquet someday yeah my god we'll
play some badminton yeah
forgotten arrow games yeah let's play
some squash but do you do you are you
enjoying it out here now yeah I mean I
have a good life out here like a really
pretty little family you know I got a
pretty girl pretty dog pretty cat no
it's tough yeah we're gonna move we're
gonna like you were doing a house thing
a house
yeah well she well she is and I'm just
gonna hit right he's yeah more more my
ship in or just Rhonda it sits on her
like she was already looking and so like
yeah so I think she's in escrow like
right now essentially it just started
like today but if it goes south she
could just [ __ ] boot you just get yep
yep just again get my stuff yeah yeah
I'm my place in New York - I bought I
bought like in like the 90s oh I'm doing
okay yeah bought a proper loft like I I
said I big syndrome
I saw the movie big and like that's what
I want so the elevator opens up to like
a big room and look at me yeah look I've
uh I have more mannequins than like you
would like think like we used to have an
American Apparel downstairs and I was
walking like out one day and there was
just a pile of mannequin parts I was
like oh my god
look if you get these look in his eye
then I told her I told my super or like
you know cuz it's in the same kind of
building complex I said listen they're
ever to get rid of like any mannequin
things like tell them to come to me
first what's a [ __ ] clothes down and
like yet like I got like I have so many
mannequins it's ridiculous
just these mannequin parts I have no
idea what to do with them either I know
I give them away like it's like presents
like here's a leg you know we'll be
talking about all the different little
cars that you bought yeah yeah but
you'll again every time I go to the
pharmacy have to buy a toy car and now
it's like I tried to double up on things
so it's like only one ambulance only one
firetruck only one Corvette ya know it's
like now it's getting ridiculous but I
for some reason I caught I like I hoard
think and I collect things like you know
and at the same time like I'll figure
out what this is for kind of thing like
you know I'll do something with those
mannequins at some point somebody like
those are gonna pay off I swear that's
the kind of [ __ ] that drives women great
raise late ladies and gentlemen I'm
going to say invest in mannequins it's a
it's a growth industry it's it there's a
high ceiling on mannequins
I'm telling you kids I think that's a
freedom thing where you do whatever you
want so you're like [ __ ] I'm just
gonna buy a man again yeah yeah yeah mmm
so yeah I when they closed down it was
like yeah I got like 20 mannequins do
you get him for free no so they were
gonna like sell them and it was
something like there was like oh we have
like 16 of them well some to you for
$500 and I said listen I said I could do
that or I could pay you you know or I
can give you $40 I can give you $200 for
them and then give you $200 because the
place is closing down so you know the
store gets the $200 but then there's
another 200 in your pocket kind of thing
because the store is closing down anyway
well cuz they're because they're not
going like they don't have a job
starting next week so they really don't
care so look yeah so I got him for
cheaper like just by pretty much bribing
the dude hmm you should offer them a
drawing I know listen man it was great
meeting you yeah you're an interesting
guy man you're very healthy for a guy
who's gotten through what you've gotten
through oh yeah it wasn't too traumatic
I you know I did it one more time your
website bunny ears calm and the podcast
it's a bunny ears pod it's you can get
it again anywhere anywhere podcasts are
done you know so like whatever things
everybody else or whatever all those
things they're listening to this they
know we're together yeah my podcasting
partner takes care of that yeah yeah
yeah that's you know like go check out
our website go check out you know
Facebook yada yada yada and say hi to
you at the human fest yeah the people in
bar Laden yeah yeah I'm gonna beautiful
thanks a lot my friend
[Applause]
[Music]